six mois de prison avec sursis pour le
cardinal barbarin pour non-dénonciation
d'agression pédophiles commis par un
prêtre de son diocèse
indépendamment de mon sort personnel je
tiens à redire d'abord ma compassion
pour les victimes et toute la place
qu'elle est leur famille garde dans ma
prière
j'ai décidé d'aller voir le saint père
pour lui remettre ma démission
il me recevra dans quelques jours je
vous remercie
une des missions que le pape françois
avait déjà refusé avant le procès la
juge a été très sévère le cardinal a
fait le choix en conscience pour
préserver l'institution de ne pas
transmettre à la justice les cas de
pédophilie qu'il connaissait le
prédateur c'est le père bernard prénat
aumônier des scouts du faubourg lyonnais
de sainte foy
il est accusé d'avoir dans les années
1970 à 90 abuser et même violé de 70 à
100 jeunes garçons de sa troupe
son procès devrait avoir lieu dans le
courant de l'année c'est la fin d'un
combat de trois ans pour l'association
des victimes
c'est une victoire que je crois qu'ils
envoient un signal très fort à beaucoup
de victimes et qui leur permettent de
comprendre que ben voilà aujourd'hui
elles sont entendus écoutés et reconnus
et je pense que
c'est un signal très fort pour elle qui
amène à la reconstruction
monseigneur barbarin et le troisième
évêque condamné en france pour des faits
similaires
la décision alors il sera peut-être
frappé d'appel on n'en sait rien mais au
niveau du symbole ya quelque chose qui
me paraît extraordinaire et je le dis
encore avec une grande émotion
historique samedi après-midi monnaie
dans laquelle photos de la paroisse
historique aussi le film grâce à dieu
primé au festival de berlin qui raconte
l'histoire des victimes du père prenne à
et l' opération de camouflage de
l'église de lyon il doit sortir en
salles au québec début avril
jean michel leprince radio canada
montréal